check this out we got the story from the
nation border patrol responsible for
portland arrest
an internal memo obtained exclusively by
the nation details a coordinated
program of domestic counter insurgency
man that sounds cool
yeah yeah that sounds so cool nailed
that
let me let me let me decontextualize
that
recontextualize it federal officers are
going to arrest
whiny progressive upper middle class
kids
that are throwing bricks at federal
buildings yeah and trying to light it on
fire
i think the reason they write it that
way and you know i'm more than happy to
use the language because it sounds fun
and exciting
now granted these guys are nuts they're
trying to bash people over that with
hammers so
yeah yeah i think it's i think it's fair
to say like
i think what's interesting about the
framing of it is that it's positive for
the federal law enforcement
to literally call antifa insurgency
justifies what the feds are doing that's
a good point
yeah it's kind of interesting yeah let's
read a little bit and i'll just show you
the straight documents
but more importantly look at this image
this is cool it's like what is this it's
like an actual photo
i mean and what i see before we even get
into it
reading that title you know what what i
think most people are thinking
cool finally yes awesome end it please
stop this it's a it's a massive pr
weapon for them
they are milking this to the most absurd
degree it's exactly the trap that was
described
and now we're seeing all the democrats
from mayors senators
all the residents people like dude these
videos out of portland yeah probably
have a collective 15 plus million views
yeah it's going it's going crazy it's
reaching which side though of antifa
destroying
being the good guys being the good guy
exactly being victimized depressed
pushing that out
yeah that's that's that's that's bad
that's very very bad for
for trump and law enforcement because
they're going to use this
and so a lot of people have said like
what should the feds do should they back
off
tough call but you know you know you
know i'm gonna say if the feds
keep cleaning up the mess for these
democrat city mayors
then these people in the cities will
keep voting for them that's a good point
it's like when you have a kid having a
temper tantrum and the parent just keeps
giving him whatever they want the kid's
never going to stop
so these people come out they destroy
the city they start romping about
starting fires
tearing down statues and the portland
government goes we're out
yep it's all you buy and then what
happens the the
federal law enforcement says okay i
guess we're going to arrest these guys
occupying army yeah let's read a little
bit
the nation writes so mind you the nation
is very left biased very important to
understand but they're the only ones
they're like this is their exclusive
you know document release so let's see
how they frame things
they say for days federal agents in
unmarked cars have reportedly been
snatching portland
protesters off the streets that's right
snatching portland
protesters okay already already we've
got it we've got to fix it okay they're
they're detaining rioters right i'm not
trying to be biased against anybody
they're literally people wearing masks
and helmets throwing things at cops
and trying to light fires literally
lighting fires
yeah yeah no they are lighting fires
right exactly protesters oh man
but i'm telling you man when these
videos go viral and you don't see any of
that
and you just see a dude putting his
hands up and they're like look at these
peaceful protesters being
being you know black bagged by unmarked
gestapo
regular people see them like whoa
because they don't know what happened
right
i got something crazy for you guys
though we got we got to talk about this
some people so here's the context right
they mentioned that the federal agents
are you know snatching up these
protesters
because the video went viral a couple of
them where a van pulls up
some guys jump out and they're wearing
like dhs patches and police but they're
in like full camo and they walk up
and a guy puts his hand up hands up and
this woman's like use your words use
your words
the feds grab the guy bring him in the
van take him away
according to one of these stories one of
these guys it might be the same guy not
sure
was questioned for about an hour and a
half before he was released
i didn't realize this i should have
realized this it's my fault
a lot of people are saying they were
snatching up on informant
that's why they weren't actually
arrested
during occupy wall street there was
somebody that
most people i would say bordering on
almost confirmed there was somebody
that everybody was like we have reason
to believe this person is a is a
confidential informant for the police
okay for a variety of reasons i'm gonna
keep it private because i don't want
anybody to you know bring this person up
but i remember one time when i was at
occupy i was getting off a train a few
blocks away
and i watched i saw the dude standing on
the corner
and then the squad car next to him two
guy two cops just grabbed him and he's
like no no what what and they arrested
him and i was like whoa
i just watched this dude get arrested
yeah for what so i go to the park and
i'm like yo i just saw this guy get
arrested
and they're like yeah so did we and i
was like
you did because i was just three blocks
away no
no right here wait a minute and so what
apparently happened was
they arrested him they arrested him in
front of everybody
in front of everybody and then when they
were dropped like they they drove him
around
asked him like what's going on what what
are you doing and then when they were
going to drop them off is when i walked
up and i was like hey
and then they grabbed him again like oh
like
he recognized him and so apparently
after the fact people were like hey we
heard you got arrested yeah i was
no no we heard you got arrested twice in
like 20 minutes no not you're talking
about
so when this story comes out where you
see a guy walking in the street
and the cops jump out and carry him to
the car and he's like whoa whoa oh no
oh no they got me that's a good point
that way they can bring him in
and he can say all right here's what
they're doing here's what they said
here's what i heard from these people
and they're like all right man good job
buddy
good you know good job officer and so
yeah and then he's like i'm gonna go
back out there
we'll just you know you guys detained me
i'll complain
we love you so that that could be it
could be a plant
it could be you know informant keep that
in mind we don't know for sure though
but this kind of distrust among these
far leftists is it runs deep
the reason these rumors are popping up
is because they're the ones probably
saying it
why weren't you charged with any crimes
right why were you brought in and cut
loose
all of us got arrested and the cops know
this and they could
pull people in specifically for this
reason sewing distrust
well i don't know at the same time we
got the you know the guy who punched the
police chief in new york city and was
released with no bail
no you can go i think that's bail reform
that's so
it's like i know that guy in the face
like
what i i don't understand
i don't get it hey 2020's been fun huh
yeah
well check us out let me just pull up
the the actual documents so these are
apparently leaked to
the nation and i gotta admit upon
looking at him
it's quite boring it does not paint this
this picture of an action movie counter
insurgency
it's literally them being like donald
trump has signed an executive order
order to protect statues and federal
facilities
we'll do we'll be deploying law
enforcement to protect federal
facilities
right it's literally like exactly as he
said but but
not even that it's like police officers
go police
there you go yeah and they're like trump
has launched a counter-insurgency and
like
they they really view themselves as
insurrectionists like revolutionaries
remember they're the resistance
i know that's just i'm so cringy i'm so
uh
i'm so deeply offended by them calling
themselves the resistance yeah like this
you know
50 year old five foot four fat balding
dude who thinks is a resistance warrior
because he sits on the computer and
complains about trump all day
like no no no no no no no air
conditioning
the dudes that were like planting bombs
to take out nazis were the resistance
you're some dude sitting in his room
complaining the orange man is bad again
yeah or posting about this check this
out
public affairs guidance cbp support to
protect federal facilities
and property they say on june 26
president the president issued an
executive order
protecting american monuments memorials
and statues and combating recent
criminal activity
in this order the president directed
that dhs shall provide as appropriate
and consistent with applicable law
personnel to assist with the protection
of federal monuments memorials statues
or property in furtherance of that
directive the acting secretary of
homeland security has formalized the dhs
protecting american communities task
force
pact to provide an ongoing assessment of
potential civil unrest and property
destruction
and to address internal resource
allocation and potential surge activity
to ensure the continuing protection of
people and property
additionally with the consent of other
departments and agencies dhs has
determined that it is in the public
interest and fiscally sound
for the federal protective service to
partner with other federal law
enforcement to execute the direction of
the president
to that end dhs began coordination with
the department of justice
and the department of the interior to
establish information intelligence
sharing
and resource coordination as outlined in
the order cbp will be supporting this
effort
by deploying personnel to provide
support over the july 4th holiday
weekend
which has the potential for increased
disruptive activity at specific
locations across the country
that could threaten our personnel and
the federal facilities and property they
protect that's
that's basically it and then it names
you know you know the executive order
and their statements and what they're
going to do and some questions what is
cbp's role blah blah blah
that's it feels like standard procedure
it
right right so some documents got
released saying hey we're going to
enforce the law
um we're going to you know talk to
people and go out and make sure people
aren't you know breaking stuff
oh oh my gosh that's the end of the
world
we know it but i'm loving the propaganda
stuff they're pumping out
totally there's like a thread that's got
10 000 retweets
and it's this like white progressive you
know
uh you know far left activist
claiming that it is it is a really
colorful depiction of of portland okay
and i gotta admit this thread
it sounds awesome it sounds great it
like makes it seem like
portland has escaped from la or like
escape from new york
they're like for the past four weeks
trump's federal army
has been storming the streets throwing
snatching people off and black bagging
them
barricading parks taking over buildings
it is a nightmare here
you have no idea they're gassing
civilians and it's like wow it's like
it really sounds like you're you're like
watching some crazy
you know you're some you're going to go
to portland and it's a bunch of whiny
20-somethings who are like
you ask the police man you're you're so
dumb
you don't even do anything and that's
and then the cops just like
you know i mean it's it's a riot you
know so people are throwing bricks
starting fires cops are firing tear gas
and all that stuff
but it's just man it's not a revolution
you want to see you want you want to see
insurrection you want to see like look
i'll give it to these kids
i say kids but some of these some of
these people are pretty old so i'll give
it some
that they certainly got anger and
conviction
you know they're going to go out and do
their thing i can i can respect the
demands but i think they're insane
regardless
but you want to watch real you know like
real like watch the ukraine stuff from
the euro maidan
i don't even what i don't know what
you'd call it protest it was it wasn't a
riot because they had barricades
they had built massive walls defending
it was like civil war almost
i guess they called it uh i don't know
what you'd call it i have no idea how
you describe it but
in this area there's one video where
like a government apc
comes up to the wall and then you just
see like dozens of molotovs just
in a second just pelting like from all
over the place
and the whole thing is just engulfed in
flames that's nuts
yeah these videos are a bunch of kids
going use your words
use your words we love you you're
violating his rights
yeah we love you we love you we'll
defend you we will get we'll get you out
ah
man but it is 48 days of just like
low tier violence and i think i think to
be fair i think there's a reason why
they're not doing like what we see in
ukraine or whatever right where they
just throw 50 miles of
cocktails at once it's because they
don't want to be on the news
yep well and you even said you were
talking to a friend of yours and they
were like
yeah well the riot writing ended like a
month exactly it's like
do you know what's going on in portland
right now georgia yeah
utah true national emergency declared in
the past week and a half
yeah it's chicago you know what's you
know what's going on in chicago you know
what's going on in new york
it's like no people are stealing bread i
hear from from aoc
oh yeah yeah so so somebody super
chatted us the other day from uh
i think it's don't walk run productions
did a video about aoc's claim that
the reason crime is going up is because
people are maybe stealing bread
and i don't know the host's name but he
was like how much bread does aoc think
is being stolen right now like crime is
up 130 something percent did you hear
what de blasio said
what did he say he said for the first
time since world war ii we've had the
lowest
amount of inmates in our prisons yeah i
know where they are
and then you stood there like this this
is it's like it's a wait
it's like it's like that meme where it's
like are you kidding me you let them all
out
if they're out there shooting everybody
but wait this reminds me of that meme uh
where it's like i think there's like a
twitter account called like obvious fact
something
and it was like you can get rid of all
criminals by making all crime legal
right like yeah if there's no crime on
the books there's literally
so so yes you can we we have we have
less inmates than we ever have
because you let them all go without like
finishing their sentences and now
you've got i think it's like 13 to 15
percent are recommitting it's like
hundreds
of of people have committed crimes crazy
and aoc
is the funniest thing she's like maybe
it's because they're scared to pay their
rent and they're hungry and are stealing
bread or something
and uh don't walk run productions points
out so clueless
they point out that like petty larceny
is down like 23 percent
like literal not only is that not what's
happening but nobody's even stealing
these things right like the crime is
gone it's the murders and the shootings
yep i love that i love that she thinks
that it's like some guy walks out and he
goes hey look there's a guy with his
daughter i need bread
bang i need to go get bread and then he
walks away like
does he frisk the guy looking for bread
he's like walk up to the dude on the
ground be like let me see where's that
bread at oh there's no bread
oh how am i gonna go get a loaf of bread
yeah that video upsets me
but like i think that really does show
that these people have no idea what's
going on in their own jurisdictions no
they're clueless
aoc is clearly clueless now she's like
fighting for
for taxing the rich the tax the
billionaires and cuomo is like no
no no yeah i know yeah no no no they'll
they'll leave town you realize right
they'll go to a different city and we
won't get their tax money
at all he said what did he say god help
us the if the wealthy leave
right so they're leaving so this is a
surprise you're gonna love this
there's a documentary about this from a
long time ago about how donald trump
saved new york city
by creating a desire for luxury
inhabitants so in the 80s and and i
could be totally wrong because i just i
just watched like i remember one night i
was just like half glazed over sitting
on the couch like it was on in the
background
that's my extent to this knowledge but
they talked about how
uh in the 80s new york was collapsing
okay you know the crime was skyrocketing
the tax base was enrolling nobody wanted
to live there
so trump basically came came in and said
give me a massive tax break
make it worth my while they fought him
on that too yeah and then he was like i
don't care
he's like but give me a tax break i'll
bring some buildings i'll get rich
people to live here your taxes your
taxes your your
uh your tax base will skyrocket that's
the trump tower right there
and then he there's multiple you've got
you've got the you've got the trump
tower on fifth well that was the start
that was that was the beginning how many
are there three are there more oh man i
mean
so here's how many that he built or that
have the name trump on it well you've
got the trump international hotel hotel
at columbus circle
you've got trump on fifth avenue and
you've got trump at the u.n
the u.n so i don't know what the trump
of the fifth avenue one is like the ice
cream shop in it that's the famous one
where he comes down the escalator yeah
yeah yeah
i actually know i hung out once with a
couple people who live
across the street from the u.n at the
other trump luxury building or whatever
and then there's the yeah and then
there's the trump international hotel
but his strategy was make it like
desirable
yeah all the rest people want to be
there you want to be cool man you want
to be like trump you have that golden
toilet
you got to come to new york and it
worked yep it did well that's that and
that's what i saw from this documentary
that was running on the background i was
like eating ice cream or something i
have no idea
but you you i don't know if you've come
across that stuff because you've been
reading a lot about it
well yeah that's why yeah that was the
uh the beginning like he they fought him
for a while
um uh mayor i think it was mayor [ __ ]
coach coach how do you say his name i
don't know what happened
yeah they were fighting they were
fighting for for a while about it
and uh trump eventually won and then
built the building but then of course
filled it out like yeah people were like
blinding up
yeah he sold one for like 10 million
dollars one one building but it's like
those taxes all one unit all went into
the city right exactly and it's like
people don't
realize the amount of like the the
ripple effect that just that one
building had
for the taxes of the city there's a uh
from i think it's the american
enterprise institute
they did a graph showing the net income
per income bracket okay and most
people receive benefits most people
don't pay in
yeah it's it's it's basically the top
ten percent
and then i think no i think it's the uh
the top twenty percent
is where you actually get a net benefit
to the government
the top one percent covers the
overwhelming majority of
of all taxes something like that you
have to look up the hard numbers
but basically during occupy wall street
there was the where the 99
movement okay where people would take
pictures saying like you know i went to
school and now i got a hundred thousand
dollars in debt and i can't pay at all
cause i work at mcdonald's i'm 99
but then something happened on the other
side where people started writing i am
the i think it's the 47 percent okay of
americans who actually pay taxes
right yeah and so according to this
graph i saw from american enterprise
institute
basically everybody pays taxes right but
what people don't realize and this is a
serious problem for us
is that if you're making like 40k a year
and you pay you know 23 or whatever in
taxes
you're probably receiving more benefit
in terms of all the infrastructure
right the you know the entirety of
public services
you're probably receiving more than
you're paying in and then you have the
rich people which are paying a
ridiculous amount
and that's exactly why trump wanted to
bring people into new york
it's exactly why andrew cuomo said
something like i think i think he said
god help us if the wealthy leave
yeah and now they're starting to leave i
i i pulled all this stuff up and did a
segment on it where i was like cuomo's
worst nightmare is here
following covet the wealthy people are
fleeing oh man she lit that city on fire
yeah this is not a joke man
amazon was going to build a second
headquarters in queens
25 25 to 40 000 jobs damn
do you have any idea how the tax base
works i'm saying this is
aoc not to you right like that one
person
who gets hired by uh by amazon they get
paid 100k a year whatever just
we'll just say 100k because it's amazon
job amazon's got to pay employment tax
then that that resident has to pay taxes
then they rent a building
they pay taxes then they start paying
into the metro system to get around
then they start buying goods sales taxes
that one person generates a
massive amount of taxes because it's not
just your paycheck
when when when i have a dollar if i give
it to you and you pay taxes on it you
get
now you have 80 cents then you give me
80 cents then i pay tax on it now i've
got 70 cents
back and forth they uncle sam keeps
taking a little bit in this instance
uncle cuomo
he's taking a little bit of cash yeah so
when you have 25 to 40 000 let's say it
was in the high end man
that was money that city needed
desperately because the mta is facing a
four
billion dollar shortfall those trains
are going to stop working
they were going to shut down the l train
for those that don't live in new york
the hot hipster neighborhood
williamsburg there's one train to get in
there from manhattan
the l bushwick yeah eastern williamsburg
well they they just kept changing the
names so so basically williamsburg was a
hot neighborhood
in order to convince people to move to
crumb your neighborhood surrounding it
they would call it like east and
southeast williamsburg
right just like change the name of the
neighborhood because people want to live
there that's bed stuy
right yeah yeah yeah sorry but so so
here's here's what happens
the l train was falling apart so they
announced they were going to suspend
service
and then i think that that was years ago
like it was supposed to have been shut
down i don't know what they're doing
yeah it was vastly approaching before i
left town i mean i skated most places i
would skate everywhere so i didn't take
the train that often
unless i needed to get somewhere quickly
and it was like dumping outside or
whatever that was yeah i would then take
the train the l train but the l train
was supposed to shut down because it it
really really needed some um
repairs it kept breaking it kept
breaking and then so they were going to
shut it down for
months no like like a year or something
oh yeah yeah maybe maybe even a year i
don't know exactly
so my so my understanding of what
happened just as someone who lived
nearby not you know following the news
that much was that property value
just tanked every everybody was
investing in this neighborhood thinking
like it's up and coming it's super hot
hipster
the l train was basically one stop from
williamsburg into manhattan it just
brought you under the water
when they announced they're going to
shut it down all of the real estate
you know owners the investors were like
no like oh man we're going to lose
everything yeah because no one's going
to want to live stuck in this little
peninsula you can't get out
so anyway long story short they ended up
suspending
the time frame and moving it whatever
this is why the amazon deal was so
important
bringing these jobs in an aoc she leads
these these protests she went down to
the financial district and she was like
amazon got to pay their fair share and
there's this really cringe video
where she walks up to the camera like
she's walking out of a meeting and then
someone asks her like
ocasio-cortez you know you know what
about amazon and she goes
can you believe they were gonna give
amazon 3 billion dollars
and then everyone was like dude it was a
discount
right they weren't giving money so
basically if if
dunkin donuts said two dollars off a
dozen donuts
she would be like i can't believe
they're gonna give people two dollars
no no no you have to buy the donuts and
they're just a little cheaper than
normal you see how that works
cyber cyber reset just uh sent it's a
little super chat said aoc is the new uh
mary antoinette
oh jesus and then it's so accurate like
what you just said
like well just give them some give them
some bread then
yeah that's basically what she's saying
why don't they just eat some bread well
if
they just want bread why don't you just
hook them up with some bread then
why not well so she so she chased out
amazon
and then started saying i don't even i
don't even represent that district why
is everyone blaming me and people were
like dude
you were like the lead like speaker
at the protest to kick them out because
you have a following and people
think they know what you're talking
about aoc that's why she kept she was
tweeting about it
and she was speaking about it and she
was wrong about it and cuomo was
was livid and local democrats were livid
and she
still won her primary how about that
that blew my mind
so now you've chased that amazon here's
the best part oh i love it so amazon
announces
they're going to open a marketing office
okay which has like a thousand employees
and she takes a picture of herself in
her lobby smiling like
and then and then she tweets like when
you're proven right and amazon comes
back
anyway and then all of these dumb
lefties are all high-fiving each other
going like yeah you know
and everyone's like first of all that is
1 000 employees not
25 000. second of all they were gonna
open that office anyway
right it's a different office marketing
that those jobs were already going to be
there
but we just lost all these other jobs
that's thank you
aoc to go back a little bit to
what's going on in portland this is why
i do not like the feds
cleaning up the mess for these
democratic mayors and governors and
whatever
yeah they want they really they they
just reelected aoc in the primary
i swear if she's gonna win the general
then new york city deserves it they're
asking for
it and trump says he's not going to give
him money good good
if listen here's the way i see it if the
people of portland will not
indict they refuse to return indictments
on these these rioters
they clearly want it yeah it's true and
if the mayor says we like
our city burning down okay then the feds
can
can go into the courthouse and defend
the courthouse and then
antifa can go around running around
destroying whatever
and give the cities what they ask for
the problem is
if you like you're a parent if you keep
cleaning up the messes for your kids
they never learn and then what ends up
happening is the more the federal
government steps in to clean up the mess
for these people
the more they keep electing them and it
gets worse
then their senators get elected and
their congress people get elected and
they go to the federal government
and they bring that mess with them
what what i think would be appropriate
is if they don't want to indict people
and they want riders running around
oh well that's it's the lo it's the
portland cops job to deal with that
not the feds yep i agree so the feds
should
guard the courthouse and just let the
riders do their thing
maybe but you know you know what someone
mentioned this that the people of
portland
they don't really care about what
happens downtown because they don't live
there
so this is the perfect opportunity for
the left to start filming feds
acting a fool you know or in i mean from
their perspective like ah look look what
they're doing
and regular people aren't there and they
won't realize so it's a perfect
propaganda opportunity
anyway long story short man you get you
you get what you vote for
you know yeah and portland didn't vote
for trump so why should
why should trump's pact be cleaning up
their messes
i don't have an answer for that yeah
they shouldn't yeah thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next
episode
you